hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar
implementation of dried blood spots dbs
for hepatitis c hcv elimination
i'm alexis cross of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by leopards and brought to you
by abbott molecular global scientific
affairs
to learn more please visit
abbottmolecular.com
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you want at any time you want during
the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
support for this program is provided by
abbott and our speakers today are
presenting at the request of abbott
i'd like to now present today's speakers
dr lisa matrow
emmanuel fajardo and dr tim meehan
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
our speakers will now begin their
presentations
good afternoon i'm alisa matrow from
german street peugeot hospital
and research institute in spain and i'd
like to thank abbott for inviting me to
participate in this webinar
i'll be talking to you about hiv
diagnosis and elimination programs
with the role of dry blood spots
so i'll start with a
little bit of a background on hepatitis
c
the global elimination strategy and then
about diagnosis and the possibilities
and
our experience with dbs so
let's start with the background
so hepatitis c virus is a small envelope
virus
with rna genome discovered in 1989
that infects the liver causing hepatitis
while acute hepatitis c is generally
mild and can be spontaneously clear by
your immune response
most infected people will develop a
chronic hepatitis c
which is often undiagnosed because
symptoms may develop
decades after infection due to advanced
liver disease
which is associated with ferrous or
liver cancer
globally hepatitis c is a global health
problem
with over 70 million people with chronic
hepatitis c
and due to shared modes of transmission
with hiv
mainly through exposure to infected
blood
hcv is also a major cause of morbidity
and mortality
in people living with hiv globally
over the last years um several direct
acting antivirals have been developed
that when used in combination can cure
hepatitis c
in almost all patients with short well
tolerated oral regimes
however access to diagnosis and
treatment
is low so how can we eliminate this
global hair problem
well mortality by viral hepatitis and
especially hepatitis c
has been increasing and even surpasses
that by other relevant infection
diseases
in the world so having an effective
treatment this cannot be allowed anymore
so in 2016 the who
launched the first global strategy on
viral hepatitis
for their elimination as a public health
threat by 2030
this means achieving a 90 percent
reduction in new cases
and 65 reduction in mortality
and how can we achieve this well we
need to perform a massive scale up in
diagnosis and treatment
from 2015 baseline to 2030 targets
of 90 and 80 percent respectively
since as you can see in this cascade of
care ftitc
is mostly undiagnosed and untreated
worldwide
but elimination targets are proving hard
to achieve as you can see in this
study in which many countries are of
track
and by many years to achieve elimination
and while production predictions have
been
optimistic in spain since the approval
of our
national plan against hepatitis c in
2015
we still need to maintain a high
diagnosis and treatment rate each year
in order to achieve elimination
so there are several um
populations that are especially
vulnerable to hcv
infection you can see them in this box
and for a variety of reasons they tend
to have
limited access to healthcare services
that's why wso and ecdc testing
guidelines
stress that we need simplified diagnosis
tests and algorithms
to expand screening out of the
healthcare setting and into the
community
this has been taken into account by our
regional plan against atlantis in
catalonia
to which i've had the pleasure to
contribute
we need to develop new patient-centered
models of testing and care
ideally offering hiv diagnosis
and treatment within those services that
these populations are already accessing
within the community
and the design of specific strategies
specifically taking into account the
needs of each one of these populations
can lead to what it's called micro
elimination
in each of them
so now i'll talk a little bit on
diagnosis
upon infection hiv rna is the first
marker to become detectable
and in acute infection as i as i said
that it may
be spontaneously clear this rna will
become undetectable
while the antibody response generated
against the virus
will generally be detectable for the
lifetime
however most infected individuals will
go on to develop a chronic infection
in this case atv rna will persist beyond
the
first six months of infection
that's why the conventional
diagnostic algorithm of hepatitis c
realize in two steps
first of all we perform a serological
test to detect htv antibodies
and this will tell us if that person has
been infected with the virus
if positive we need to go on and perform
a second test confirmatory test
detecting hiv rna
in order to determine if this person
has a viral infection and is in need of
treatment these two tests are
conventionally performed in two
different
samples of venipunctured blood and
this causes losses to follow up in
in the in the two-step algorithm
this may be simplified by performing
both tests from the same beneficial
blood sample
but still diagnosis of hepatitis c
requires multiple visits to healthcare
centers
the use of any puncture and fresh blood
requires
a certain conditions for storage and
shipment to the laboratory
including cool chain
so that's why over the last few years
new diagnostic strategies have been
designed
in order to bring diagnosis closer to
affected people
in this end dried blood spots which are
an alternative minimally invasive
specimen
have proved very useful and it may also
facilitate
the simplification of the diagnosis
algorithm
as we said performing reflex testing on
the same sample
or even performing direct rna testing
in this what we call one step testing
or even facilitate the the introduction
of
new screening strategies such as home
sampling
or integrated multi-testing screening
and facilitate decentralization
not only of diagnosis but also treatment
monitoring
so tripod spots are a few drops of
capillary blood that are collected and
let's try
on two special paper cards
we actually like to measure the
appropriate volume of blood and we use
this minivet
or edta capillaries in order to do it
but you could also directly transfer
the drops of blood into the
paper card that we use uh watman parts
but without touching it with the skin as
this could lead to
deterioration of the sample so
the most important thing is that the
plot needs to be completely dry before
storage and we store it with a desiccant
we use one with a humidity indicator
for a quality purposes and then
they these samples are stable and can be
shipped to the laboratory through
regular email
we have this small instructions for
collection centers so the use of bright
blood spots
has the support from testing guidelines
and being such a minimally invasive
sample that is easy to collect they
provide virtually
universal access to diagnosis
because they can be even collected by
not
healthcare workers but community workers
and and they can be shipped from
temperature to the laboratory
and they are good for the detection of
both antibodies
and rna and even just for other
bloodborne viruses on the other hand
of course we are using a very low
volume of blood and then the sensitivity
may be
somewhat lower than in plasma for the
detection
of the viral rna the
instructions need to be carefully
followed in order to ensure the
stability and the quality of the sample
and until now testing has been mostly
performed in specialized labs
because of the lack of a limited
availability
of commercial essays with regulatory
approval for the use of dba samples
of course this is not a rapid test so
results need to be delivered
at the second visit
as you can see in this meta-analysis
the detection of hcbrna from dba shows a
very high
diagnostic position when we look at both
commercial and
in-house essays
and there has been a concern regarding
the sensitivity of these alternative
essays but we have to make such an
effort to reach
20 30 targets with 90
of diagnosed people that the wso
has a limit suitable all those tests
that are able to improve access and or
affordability
that at least can detect 3 000
international units per amount
and the european clinical guidelines
talk about
1000 and this level levels of arrhenia
can be detected
in 95 to 97
of all chronic infections you have to
bear in mind that unless we use these
alternative testing methods
many people worldwide will not have
access to conventional diagnosis of
the diabetes
so in our experience uh back in in 2015
we set up an in-house qualitative
real-time pcr
essay for the detection of hepatitis c
and internal control
we validated in in our lab with um
hepatology patients in in our outpatient
visit in our hospital
and it shows by high sensitivity and
specificity as you can see
in this more recent meta-analysis and
later on we perform a real-world
validation in people who inject drugs
showing as well a good sensitivity and
specificity
when considering the limits established
by the
and compared to the viral load testing
in plasma
the other design is based on previous
methods developed in scotland by
bennett at r but we use some
modifications in order to simplify the
process
so we perform a single step
retrotranscription and real-time pcr
and we use a commercial uh internal
control
so basically we punch out two spots
uh we use this first kind of a
puncture that we sterilize by farming in
between samples
some other tools or even scissors can be
used
and then we elite the blood from the
paper card
by um incubation with the lysis buffer
and
um orbital shaker
then we go on and perform automatic
running extraction
the pcr setup is performed manually and
then
finally we do the amplification and
detection
in a single step for both the appetite
tcrna
and an internal control that is an
unrelated rna that we add to each sample
in order to monitor the whole process
we also use positive and negative
controls in each rung
so how do we use this test in
intermediate prevalence populations that
attend
community centers we recommend to first
use
an antibody rapid test
for instance in our fluid or capillary
blood
and if positive right away we can
collect the dbs sample
while in high prevalence populations we
do the one-step rna testing
since prevalence in for instance in
people who inject drugs
may have reached 90 percent so it's not
no use on
using an antibody test first so we
directly collect
um the dvs sample and
in both cases we ship these samples at
room temperature to the laboratory for
hiv rna testing and results are giving
back
to the community center so i'll show you
some examples of each of these two
strategies
in our first project with pbs we
screen men who have sex with men and
sexual workers attending an ngo in
barcelona
and we train the community workers
at this ngo in hiv testing
counseling and dvs collection
and we showed that those tests have very
high accessibility
and while uh hcp prevalence was similar
to that in the general population which
is below one percent in spain uh based
on this and uh
other a couple of other studies um
last year and this protocol of community
screening
of hepatitis c in hiv negative
men who have sex with men and
transgender women
was uh implemented in as part of our
regional plan
also migrants from endemic countries
foreign dc
will need to be screened and we
developed this
epsilon project which is a micro
elimination pilot
in pakistan immigrants in barcelona
so what we did we trained community
health agents in hepatitis
screening and counseling and then they
perform community events
in which they use an interactive
educational tool
and perform on-site screening with rapid
antibody testing and if positive they
collected the via sample
for the confirmation of the viral rna
this way we are able to provide
simplified linkage to care and treatment
for viral patients needing the antiviral
treatment
and this this project is being also
now expanded to
hepatitis b and also people from other
endemic countries
and as part of the regional plan is also
implemented in other areas in catalonia
then on the fc detector project we're
performing people who actively inject
drugs
we set up dvs testing in forum
for harm reduction services in the
personnel
province and we demonstrated
the feasibility of dbs collection
by the harm reduction center staff
including also one mobile unit
and as we said before we
demonstrated a high reliability of the
test
in real world conditions and this
enabled us to determine for the first
time the prevalence
of ceramic infection in this and this
population
in our setting and also
among byramic patients the 35 percent
were not aware of their status
these results were published last year
and included in this compilation
of new bundles of care for drug services
also in people who inject drugs we
compare
the usefulness and reliability of our
dbs test
with a rapid point of care test
detecting
hiv rna by gene expert platform
and as you can see here when taking into
account consideration the limits
established by the who
we demonstrated that both alternative
deaths are highly reliable
and they will enable to also
facilitate centralized not only
diagnosis but
treatment and we are collaborating in
this microelimination project
with hospital cleaning so
very recently in within our regional
plan
this protocol has been approved in which
this alternative testing strategies will
be
offered to people who use drugs
so in conclusion simplified htv rna
detecting strategies
based on dna facilitate access to
diagnosis
and self-knowledge of dynamic infection
in a simple and reliable way as long as
quality
can be assured and they can help
decentralize not only diagnosis but also
treatment and monitoring of rain
infection
as suggested initially by gentiles
and its implementation will help meet
elimination targets
not only improving the diagnosis rate
but also monitoring the epidemics
as we also use it to estimate the gas
the cascade of care
in people who inject drugs obviously
this has been an effort of a
multidisciplinary collaboration
and i'd like to thank all the involved
people who made this possible
and also funding sources and of course
thank you for your attention
so now i'll pass it to the next speaker
thank you
hello everybody this is daniel fajardo
and i'm working with
find in the hepatitis program and i'm
very delighted today
to share some of the results of our
study
to evaluate dry blood spots for rna
testing
so thank you to all the participants who
are joining this webinar
and so today i will walk you through
some of the
outcomes of this study i'll show you the
background the methodology and the
results for the abut
dbs rna testing
yes so as previously mentioned by the
speakers there's
many challenges in trying to reach all
those people who are infected with
hepatitis c
this graphics from the whole report in
2018
highlighting that there is a high
proportion of people infected with hcv
who aren't aware of their status
and there are many reasons for this one
is that the many countries
they love the policies to support
testing
but also one of the main critical issues
is really the laboratory capacity
but also the complexity to diagnose
hepatitis c
so unlike hiv for hepatitis we need
in addition to the antibody testing we
need the viral load
to be able to confirm active infection
or virenia
unfortunately the gold standard to a
determined dynamic
is relies on plasma usually in
centralized labs
and as mentioned before there are many
programmatic issues
one of those is really the sample
referral networks especially in low
middle-income countries
where you need a cold chain to transport
all these plasma samples
you also need some citric huges to to
get the plasma
if you do require some resources so this
is very challenging in many countries
but over the last decades there'll be a
lot of the system strengthening our
laboratory strategy in many countries
and
there are platforms already in place uh
nucleic acid testing platforms that are
also used for other diseases
so of course this offers a very good
opportunity for integration
amongst different diseases
so in order to overcome the issues with
the sample transportation of plasma
the dry blood spot has been identified
already for many years as a very
practical option to to collect this
sample
and conduct not only are imitating but
for other
testing that has antibody testing or
resistance testing
so it offers a lot of uh practical uh
benefits uh because you decentralize
combo collection
and it's very important from a patient
perspective because sometimes
when the transport system is very poor
in many in many countries then the
patient has to come again to the clinic
too much with it with it with example
with a transport
schedule so this interlining sample
collection is if
it does help in avoiding dropouts of
patients
and of course as you get rid of the cold
chain
the reduction in prices will also be
important
um there is already as mentioned before
there is some
studies that have shown that using dry
blood support for
rna testing is highly accurate and this
graph in your lab
shows the the the summary of the studies
as part of the meta-analysis
where they look at the performance of
dbs for rna testing
and the pool sensitivity was 98 and the
specificity was also very high
this is really good but at the same time
many of these studies have some
shortcomings because
they use a variety of different
technologies
mainly use in-house methods there are
there were also commercial methods but
the
the procedure to test dbs uh are not
standardized in this process in these
studies so for example the number of the
spots or the
or the volume of blood you couldn't feel
the paper it just varies a lot
so you know most of the this is study
use
a methods that are off-label so it means
the manufacturers have not validated it
and and also most of the studies have
been carried out in central labs you
know
usually in reference a lot of
universities
so there is a lack of a performance
studies in real life
so that's why with this study fine it's
intending to
try to answer some of the questions in
in terms of the
performance of the dry blood spots
compared to plasma
using fingerprint or venous blood
we also as part of this multicentury
study we're also evaluating other
technologies
that are commonly used for hiv for
hepatitis c
and hiv of course which include the
roach and the holy logic
but the results of this will be shared
today
so the the number of sites that
participated in this multi-country
study are four so you see here in the
map it's cameron
is greece georgia and rwanda so we try
to have a very
diversified geographical representation
and besides in all these countries the
abbot
was already implemented
australia acted as a reference lab
within all the dry blood spots to
australia for
further testing
these are the different platforms that
are part of this study with the combo
with the m2000
software preparation system and we use
only dbs
all countries camaro georgia greece and
rwanda they
they have the system quite for rush and
for how logic it was done only in
australia so we ship all the samples to
australia for their testing
then the the the people who participated
in this
study the recruitment strategy was that
we identified three
distinct groups so one was people who
have a who are antibody positive for
hepatitis c
also people who are at risk of hepatitis
c
so with some risk factors like people
who inject drugs or
people or people with tattoos and the
same hiv positive etc
and also people who have already been
exposed
to the treatment or through dias
this slide shows you a little bit of the
sample workflow it looks a little bit
busy but it's basically
every participant a
fingerprint was conducted and all the
filter papers they
were completed and and also the
the windows blog was collected in the
edti apta
and then it was centrifuge to get plasma
and of course also to conduct the
the testing um in these countries
uh the the people who carried out this
sample collection
differ so for example in cameroon it was
mainly the laptop legions
in georgia it was in the nurses and
english was actually
the physicians so we collected it for
example for the fingerprint we did use a
volumetric
kind of pipette to be able to measure
the 70 microliters of blood that is
recommended for filter paper
we follow a standard procedure for all
sides
and and then we tried also to
keep the dbs at room temperature until
testing
so that it mimics a real-life situation
then after all these procedures we
proceed to do the other testing
with the with the protocol provided by
the company which is the open mood
protocol for dbs
here in this slide it's showing um
[Music]
the results the turnaround time from
blood collection
to rna testing so this box plot
shows you the median time you know in
terms of the days and the y-axis
it shows you the days and the in the
x-axis is the different
type of test so plasma dbs capillary the
village blood and you will see for
example that in increase
they they tested very quickly within a
week or a
medium of 10 days they were already
doing all the testing
and the same georgia well for cameroon
there were some delays so the turnaround
time was extended
in all sides as i said before we tried
to keep the dry blood spots
at room temperature but because of the
extended timeline we had to
resort to you know to use cold chains so
that degradation of rna
did not take place
these are the results of the
demographics and
so i will not describe them all in
detail but just wanted to highlight
a for example that in all
countries most of the participants were
male except in cameroon that
we have 58 of the participants who were
women
also the number of people
infected with hiv was rather low so we
only have three percent of participants
with hiv contraction
and also the number of people that go to
treatment was
was only 13 almost 100 participants
have been exposed to dias
in this slide i'm showing the
distribution of the genotypes across the
countries
you will see there is a total in general
genotype one was the most common a
genotype called world four
and three also a as part of this study
we also
wanted to evaluate the you know the the
sensitivity of the driver spot to
detangle these genotypes
so in this graph it's showing the
sensitivity
across all genotypes for the for venus
blood ddbs and vocabulary
so he detected all the genotypes
in this slide i'm showing the results of
capillary dbs
across the three countries i did not
mention that rwanda was
still ongoing so i we don't have results
here
so it's only for these countries so here
you show
you can see the distribution of viral
loads by the sample type
and you see that it's very similar
between plasma and
tbs but in general the
dry dark spots tend to be lower compared
to plasma
which is expected as the the volume of
blood is much lower
but interestingly in cameroon we found
that
the the actually the wire loading the
drive block spot was a little bit
higher than a plasma
and we could be you know we think maybe
it has something to do with the
correction factor
but overall if they were the the the
distribution of virulent is very similar
to
plasma in this slide i'm showing the
correlation
between the the dps the capillary and
the plasma
you can see that there is a strong
linear correlation between
both samples and also in your in your
right in the graph of the body you see
the distribute the difference
between tps and plasma and the main
difference
here was 0.2 log
so it means to 0.2 log plumbing it was
really zero point to look a little bit
higher than dbs
okay then we conducted the sensitivity
and specificity analysis
which is the primary endpoint of this
evaluation so here in this
slide i'm showing the results by country
on the top and below with the pool
sensitivity
so you can see there for example the
sensitivity georgian cameo
was kind of similar 99
but it was reduced slightly in greece it
was 90
specificity was high ninety five percent
one hundred percent
then the same for grades and the value
rate
was very low so when we tried to compare
the results between george and cameron
we see they're not
statistically significant but they were
significant between georgia and grace
in terms of sensitivity that means 99
versus 90 um
in the next slide i'm showing them the
results for the windows blood
so connected with ddta cold blooding
spotted on the filter paper
so again the results are very similar
very strong
a linear correlation between plasma and
the venous blood
and the same the difference between
plasma also was 0.
0.1 log in general and most of the
the results different was below the 0.5
log
these are the the results of the
sensitivity and specificity for the
venus bds
so the results are exactly very very
similar to the capillary one
with the same trend in terms of crease
showing a little reduced sensitivity
the in the overall but overall all sides
you can see the sensitivity is 95
and specificity is 97 while also having
a very low invalid rate
this is the distribution of the viral
loads by
sample type of venus blood and plasma so
similar to capillary
a i've mentioned before and sorry
as mentioned before the the var load
tended to be a little bit lower
in in the venus dbs in georgia
and in great but it is finally
higher income
we also conducted the analysis according
to the population groups as i mentioned
before we have three
distinct groups that were recruited
those are positive
at risk and people on treatment and you
can see that this sensitivity
for his specificity for those of us
positive and high risk was
quite good but for people on treatment
it was reduced it was only 65
sensitivity
and of course you would expect that all
these patients have a much lower bar
load
okay so basically it means that of the
92
participants that have received
treatment dbs detected only
13 out of the 20. so there were seven
close negatives to so to go further in
detail to look at
those seven false negatives you can see
here the respective plasma concentration
and the dbs that came undetected
and of course the concentration in
plasma is very low so efficiently
quantifiable but
under the limit of detection of the sa
so it was most of the full results
and they tended to be very very low
interestingly there was a dbs was able
to
detect rna in example as low as the 600
range so here the this question around
the threshold to
to use for dbs to evaluate the
performance becomes quite important
so as mentioned previously in the in the
first
talk uh you know the the iso guidelines
the
the european association for the study
of the liver they recommend a 1000
threshold
for settings where access to a var load
is limited
here i'm also putting the limited
detection of
of the abbot dbs method which is 462.
so um to
to further elaborate on that in this
graph
i'm showing so it's a little bit busy
but basically i'm
highlighting here this is the very low
distribution in my
among all those patients in treatment
so more than 65 of the participants are
actually very high bar loads so the
median
the bar load was 5.6 log
in dbs or with plasma meaning that
you could still detect those
participants who were already exposed to
dea
so just as a conclusion of this study
so the the study confirms that the
performance of the dbs
is very good it's very high and you can
still use either capillary or venus
blood
um compared to the golden standard when
we compare
the sensitivity of of this study with
the food sensitivity is very similar and
actually it overlaps with the confidence
intervals of the full sensitivity and
the thing for
for the specificity so
yeah we confirm it's good performance
however we did see the variability right
between for example grease and the other
side that had a lower sensitivity
in the gps you know i still because of
the different sample type it
is subject to some kind of variability
in terms of repetition in europe in the
test it will give you a slightly
different result
and this difference could be in the
range of 0.25 log difference
which is normal according to the sample
type
also another consideration or finding is
for example the specificity of the dbs
in the
in the group of participants that were a
treatment experience
was 100 percent meaning that
if you use dds for sbr all those people
who are undetected they will be
correctly identified as undetected
to confirm the cure however you know
whether dbs would be useful to identify
patients who are failing treatment
and who are experiencing a low-level
viremia
need to be further analyzed and the
threshold
the the the clinical threshold to be
used for this
needs to be established so
i think this is the end of my
presentation of course
this work was a great collaboration
between different partners
and i would like to thank all the
participants in the different countries
who decided to participate
in the different partners that
collaborated with this
study thank you also to abort for the
invitation
and and then i handle it to the next
speaker thank you very much
thank you very much for the previous
speakers my colleagues
as well as to abbott for the opportunity
to present
today i'm going to be discussing the
potential to
increase the access to hcv testing
in low to middle income countries
through the use of dried blood spot
my name is timothy meehan and i work for
clinton health access initiative or
otherwise known as chai
before diving into bright blood spot dbs
i think it's helpful
to once again frame the discussion by
quickly walking through
the testing cascade which is employed in
many
lmics low and middle income countries
for reference this cascade is also
exhibit one of chai's recent hcb market
intelligence report
the testing begins with individuals
having either a rapid test an rdt or
a lab-based amino acid which detects the
presence
of hcv antibodies in blood
those individuals who test positive are
referred
to for reflex test testing with a blood
draw that's sent to a centralized
facility typically and this involves a
viral load test
those individuals who test positive
for viral load are then put on pen
genotypic treatment
and following treatment 12 weeks later
they are once again have a blood draw
for the viral load
to assess the sustained viral response
at week 12
also known as svr 12.
there is currently a reliance on liquid
or plasma samples
and centralized viral load testing which
can limit the access for some
individuals to testing and subsequently
treatment
it's important to note that centralized
testing of plasma samples is only one
of several barriers to scale up of hcv
but
it is an important barrier to increasing
the access to testing
there's also a recognized need for
patient-centered testing in other words
to bring the test to the patient
not the patient to the testing facility
and there is currently a limited
availability of true
point of care options which would enable
a distributed
hcv diagnosis in many low and middle
income countries
dbs has the opportunity to increase
access to testing
and treatment therefore through
decentralized sample collection
via dbs we can help circumvent the lack
of
centralized sorry decentralized and
point-of-care testing
there are a number of lessons that can
be learned in some overlap
with the successful implementation of
dried blood spots for hiv
and many of these lessons can be applied
to expanding
dbs for hcv
these opportunities may only be realized
however
if the program is properly supported to
handle the sample collection
the transportation the results return
which of course would also involve
significant funding
there are a number of advantages that
dbs has
over liquid samples in terms of
transportation storage
as well as sample collection uh while
there are of course
challenges that remain uh i'll be going
into these advantages in a bit more
detail
dbs has fewer transportation and storage
constraints than liquid samples
for example the constraints of liquid
samples are that
whole blood may only be stored at
ambient temperatures for
about six hours or maximum of 24 hours
if the whole blood is spun down to
plasma using
centrifuge which requires some level of
laboratory infrastructure
refrigerated plasma must be tested
within five six days
or otherwise would need to be frozen for
longer term storage
any break in the cold chain or delays in
transportation may degrade the the
liquid samples
and subsequently make them unfit for
testing requiring
new samples to be obtained with
potentially significant challenges
in relocating those individuals
liquid samples therefore must be
transported quickly
which can result in sub-optimal
transportation
from low-volume sites and as an example
of this
we can imagine a facility which has a
low sample collection
frequency they perhaps only receive a
couple samples per week
and that the pickup of the plasma must
still occur on a frequent basis
thereby increasing the first sample
transportation cost and burden
for low volume sites so you know for
example if a rider can
transport 20 samples but only one sample
comes in per week
that one sample still needs to be
transported
in contrast dbs is stable for at least
several months at ambient temperature
and some studies have shown this to be
stable even for up to a year and
dbs may be transported by just the
simple post or
a courier without any need for a cold
chain
other potential advantages of dbs in
terms of sample collection
are around the use of a finger stick
which is less invasive
and no need for venipuncture or
therefore qualified philbottomist
they also don't need to use a centrifuge
to spin down the blood to plasma which
limits the reliance upon so even a low
level of laboratory infrastructure
dbs facilitates testing for individuals
who may have difficulty providing venous
samples for a variety of reasons and
this can
include dehydration illness or injection
drug use
sample collection by a healthcare worker
is actually rather similar to the
training
needed to administer a rapid test and
rdt
to detect for those who are antibody
positive
and this may enable the immediate reflex
dbs collection following a positive
screening result
so we can imagine a scenario where a
number of people have gathered
for screening and testing and those
who test positive for antibodies doesn't
necessarily mean that they have active
uremia
they can immediately be reflex tested
for
uh viral load by collecting a dbs sample
at that time
then therefore potentially limiting the
loss to follow up
and or limiting them needing to go
someplace else to a testing facility
to have a venous blood draw occur
well there may be many drivers for
uptake which can vary by country and
location
some of the primary enabling and
need-based drivers
can include the following there the
availability of a robust postal or
courier network
can enable dbs to be transported readily
another enabling factor is the existence
of
dbs for hiv which may enable
dry blood spot for hcv this can be
imagined by leveraging the hiv dbs
sample transport network
also integration of hcv within the hiv
dbs work stream is possible
there are some need-based drivers such
as the
gaps within an existing liquid sample
transportation network
these could be the limited availability
of qualified healthcare workers
such as phlebotomists or laboratory
staff necessary to
store spin down the samples to plasma
limited facility network coverage
infrequent pickups from remote or just
simply low volume
low sample volume sites where uh liquid
sample transport from certain facilities
may not be cost effective dues just
simply due to the low volume or the
geographic remoteness or
a number of other factors or just the
overall high cost of liquid sample
transportation
due to a number of factors including the
need for cold chain storage
there are a potential a number of
potential market
and demonstrated performance knowledge
gaps that still need to be
addressed and can act as challenges to
the implementation
on a wide scale of dbs for hcv
for example an updated assessment of the
increased access to hcv testing that
would be enabled
by dbs could help drive uptake
while there is some evidence that dbs
can be less expensive than plasma based
upon the cost of goods
the lack of cold chain and a few other
factors
it would be valuable to have a broadly
applicable cost comparison
of dbs to plasma and an assessment of
the key drivers of cost both for
liquid and dried samples
and finally a widely accepted
performance of dbs
for hcv diagnosis and confirmation of
cure svr svr12
and this will be enabled by my colleague
from finds a soon to be published report
that will look at global levels of
dbs performance
in conclusion there are a number of
potential activities
which would be needed to implement dbs
in lmics
and these may include publication of
independent performance evaluation of
hcv dbs such as the fine study soon to
be
published student regulatory approval
of dbs which will enable countries to
adopt it
funding to roll out hcv dbs programs
sensitizing in ministries of health and
hcb programs in countries to the
opportunities and the challenges
of dbs for hcv and updating
country guidance in-country
registrations performance validations
as they are necessary a number of other
factors that need to occur in country
to truly enable the use of hcv
for sorry for dbs for hcv
in conclusion although there are
remaining potential market and dentistry
performance challenges
there are also a wide range of
advantages and
opportunities for dbs to increase the
access to testing and treatment for
hepatitis c
and at this point i would like to pass
it back to the moderators
to handle any questions from the
audience and i thank you for your
attention
thank you alisa emmanuel and tim for
your informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for so
let's get started our first question is
for elisa
what were some of the challenges that
you encountered
which the eight with the hcv-c detect
program you supported in spain
elisa are you there
you know we can we can come back to a we
can go back to
alisa let's go to i have a question for
emmanuel
hi hi i'm sorry i had a problem with the
button
can you hear me now yes we can elisa
thank you so much let me repeat the
question for you what were some of the
challenges that you encountered which
with the hcv c detect program that you
supported in spain
wow thank you yes we have sometimes the
problem
of the the size of the spots uh we need
four completely full spots of blood and
sometimes they are not so easy to
collect from
certain people so uh but usually
when insisting to people collecting them
that this is an important
question that the sports need to be
completely full
uh it's all the tip so
that's okay
now emmanuel uh we have a question for
you and this is a
two-part question two-thirds of the
sites observed false positives with dbs
since hcv does not integrate with into
cells like hiv
pro-viral contamination wouldn't be an
issue
could you comment on potential causes of
these false positives
and are there procedural steps that
could contribute to this performance
yeah thank you very much for the
question
yes that's correct two out of the three
sites experience
some false positives i did not include
in the presentation that
on repeat testing these dbs results were
actually negative
so confirming that they were false
positives
and one of the reasons why there could
be a potential for cross-contamination
is in that procedure is when you process
the dbs samples
so for example and also the type of
filter paper that you use
so in this study we use the watchman
paper which needs to be cut but there
are
some other filter papers that are
actually pre-cut
so you just need to push the filter
paper with the tip
to detach the the spots from the card
and this i think this type of card would
reduce
the potential for cross-contamination so
this is definitely
an area and of course you know this asop
to be able to process all the db samples
needs to be followed very properly
so these results highlight the
importance you know of
you into the sop and also the type of
filter paper that you use
i hope that answers your question that
was great so
let's go over to tim you discussed
number of potential activities which are
needed to implement
hcv dbs in lower middle income countries
would you agree that funding to roll out
this program seems to be most
challenging one
to overcome and do you expect that these
programs will continue to be supported
nationally rather than by ngos
yeah it's a really good question and of
course funding is always
one of the major challenges without
funding programs cannot happen
that said it really depends on a country
by country basis there are a number of
countries
such as rwanda that have very
significant
government budget lines for hcv programs
and are on the course toward elimination
and so in these instances this isn't
necessarily a dependence upon global
donors
that there is a lot of funding behind
this at the national level
there's also a number of states within
nations such as punjab haryana in india
nasarawa state and nigeria that have
specific
line items within their state budgets
that are funding hcv programs
now elisa will come back to you how long
can an
hcv remain contagious in dried blood
on a hard surface or in a needle
well in this case um according to
to spanish regulations blood spot or
once the the blood has been dried on a
paper
uh it's it's not considered a really
contagious
and especially if it's wrapped up in
this
plastic bag that we carry them so that's
why they can be shipped through
a regular postal mail postal service
but uh of course if you if you're
considering needles like in people who
inject drugs of course uh very few
uh um traces of blood maybe still be
contagious because they're
um humid or it still has some
some kind of liquid in there
but for for dry dry blood
it should be safe
so we'll go back over to emmanuel um
emmanuel we have another couple part
question for you
um what was the definition of hcv
treatment exposure and were people on
treatment what
study was done or had they already been
cured
yeah so thanks for the question so the
definition
for a hdb treatment group is that
any participant attending the clinic
either for sbr 12 because he
he was scheduled for sbr 12 or whether
they had already completed treatment
so that was the definition for the hcv
treatment group
so it means that we had patients that
had completed treatment
several months ago and we did the
testing but also some that came
specifically for the measurement of sbr
12.
and then that last oh i'm sorry continue
no no i hope i hope this clarifies a bit
sure and then there was one last
question to that one was why would you
expect them to have detectable hcv rna
if they had already been treated
yeah because there could be some
treatment failures
for example you could see that there
were patients with high viral loads
after being treated
so of course they would be classified as
treatment failure
after being receiving the the regimen
with dnas
and it looks like we might have time for
one or two more
questions so this one again is for you
emanuel
um did you say that you needed three
finger sticks to properly collect the
dbs sample
and what was the acceptability for this
in the patients
yeah that's correct the the number of
because of the number of the
different sample types that were
collected you know have you have the the
the finger breaking in different
filter papers uh different fingerprints
were necessary
uh but in general the participants did
not
complain i mean there was a high
acceptability rate which is interesting
because i know there's been a lot of
studies uh discussing about
how much how many the participants may
not like to
participate if you do a lot of finger
break but you know
this study the acceptability it was very
high
great and it looks like
that would be that is going to be our
last
question but we would like to thank you
again alisa emanuel
and tim for your time today and for your
important research
we would also like to thank labbert and
our sponsor abbott molecular global
scientific affairs
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker
via the contact by the speakers excuse
me via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labberts will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live events
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and until next time
goodbye